Sophia the first is a TV show like no
other it's one of the first kid shows to
feature some of our favorite Disney
Princesses and it looks like Sophia the
first and frozen might be crossing
worlds sooner than later so this is what
a party looks like watch until the end
to find out about the mind-blowing
connections Anna Elsa and Sophia share
we've seen a ton of Disney Princesses
find their way into Sophia's adventures
through her magical amulet it even
brought her one of Disney's most elegant
Princesses Cinderella what are you doing
here in fact Cinderella was the first
princess to appear on the show and seen
as Cinderella fans absolutely loved this
Princess duo Disney decided to keep the
tradition going we got to see some
amazing episodes involving Princess
Jasmine Belle Ariel and Aurora in season
1 of Sofia the first
Snow White Mulan Rapunzel and tiana also
made appearances in season 2 and come
season 3 Princess Merida and the
adorable Olaf finally joined Sofia's
cameo gang now that pretty much sums up
all of the official Disney Princesses
with the exception of Pocahontas of
course maybe it's not too late to stop
this but she isn't the only missing
character of the show that fans want to
see if you're a fan of Sofia the first
you've probably heard about the theories
that tie princess Sofia
to the frozen world what you looking for
you might have also heard that Sofia
Anna and Elsa have a lot more in common
than meets the eye one popular theory is
that Sofia is actually Elsa and Ana's
mother we know what you're thinking
Sofia is younger than Elsa and Anna but
here's the real kicker we have no idea
which timelines she's actually living in
now this isn't too far-fetched
considering that Cinderella once
mentioned your amulet brought me here it
links all the princesses that ever were
after some internet digging we found a
theory that might just hold up brought
to you guys by amino apps user Callie
the title of the theory is theory 96
just in case you guys wanted to check it
out the user mentions that Sofia might
actually be the reason that Elsa has
powers in the first place if you watched
our video Disney Princess family secrets
then surely
you recall that Rapunzel is cousins with
Elsa and Anna and theory 96 clearly
points out that the connection between
the arendelle sisters and the caronian
cousin in the end it all comes down to
the magical golden flower that appears
in a number of Disney movies like
tangled and frozen entangled we find out
that the magical flower emanated from a
single drop of sunlight that fell from
the heavens
once it touched ground and began to grow
into a beautiful golden flower that was
known for captivating any and all
Wanderers who happened upon it this
flower has the ability to heal illnesses
and erase wounds like it was no big deal
it also supplied anyone who used it with
a figurative Fountain of Youth which is
why Mother Gothel was so obsessed with
it and if her puns his father had never
offered the golden flower to his wife
Mother Gothel would not have needed to
steal Rapunzel and use her newly magical
hair to rejuvenate her appearance this
golden flower has no shortage of cameos
in the Disney verse not only does it
appear entangled but it also appeared in
Moana and most importantly Sofia the
first in the episode of Sofia the first
we clearly see the Sun drop flower
receive some screen time when we come
face to face with the Wicked nine the
Wicked nine consists of nine magical
items and lo and behold the Sun drop
flower has made it into this famous
grouping but wait what is it doing in
Sofia's kingdom didn't it only exist in
arendelle Corona and MOTU Nui well
here's where things get interesting we
soon find out that the Wicked 9 is made
up of magical items that were once owned
by Disney Villains
if our wind combines the items have the
potential to unleash unspeakable power
knowing this a group of protectors were
chosen to discard these dangerous items
all over the ever realm and many fans
believe the ever round to go hand in
hand with the Disney Universe we soon
see Sofia enter a magical library in the
secret library episode this library
holds a story about the Sun drop flower
which we know is the reason that
Rapunzel has her powers so what if clean
Doudna got sick before elsa was born and
needed to use the power of this flower
this could be true considering that King
agna are told the trolls that Elsa was
born with her powers and hadn't been
cursed so why do Elsa and her
they'll have very different powers well
our take on this theory is that the
flower affects people in different ways
it caused Rapunzel to heal because the
flower was predominantly used to heal a
fetus
so perhaps Rapunzel's healing and
rejuvenation powers stems from this
primary need whereas queena Doudna who
lived in a colder climate might have
been suffering from a cold and consumed
the flower while its petals were frozen
another theory is that the flower simply
activates curses that were previously
placed on its consumers ancestors in
frozen the ancient relative and King
ignores book looks like he was placed
under a curse and luckily the trolls
were able to lend a helping hand and try
to extrude the evil magics from his body
the reason the golden flower might be
able to activate an ancient curse is
that the flower once belonged to the
wicked nine and these items were not
meant to be used for personal reasons by
anyone belonging to the Disney kingdoms
we all know that the king of enchancia
'he's first wife passed away even though
he knew about the flower so is it
possible that because he obeyed the laws
of the kingdom and avoided using the
flower his ultimate selfless deed was
enough to grant him the amulet that
Sophia is now in possession of this
would make sense but you know would also
make sense if Sophia was one of the
protectors who hid the wicked nine
around the world this could very well
mean that she's older than Anna and Elsa
so by default it could be possible that
Elsa Anna and Sophia are related in some
way shape or form knowing this we can
see why Olaf made an appearance on the
show while Anna and Elsa have yet to
follow could this be because they aren't
born yet let us know what you think
about this theory in the comments below
and be sure to drop some theories of
your own and that's a wrap give this
video a big thumbs up if you love Disney
Princesses thanks for watching the
things we'll see you next time
[Music]